[Música]
en una galaxia muy muy lejana y muy
famosa que todos conocemos hay
diferentes tipos de líderes
por ejemplo estos dos líderes icónicos
darth vader y maestro yoga
darth vader es un líder técnicamente
competente es un buen piloto es un buen
guerrero tienes un norte estratégico muy
claro darth vader ejerce un control de
un control un poder fuerte sobre las
personas para lograr sus metas él ejerce
un liderazgo de control absoluto
por lo tanto tienes seguidores todos
uniformes todos iguales
sumisos dóciles y eso no sé por qué con
muy mala puntería
su eterno rival maestro yoda
él no pide sumisión
y ahora pide un conocimiento ontológico
un conocimiento de tu ser y ahora pide
que para servir una causa que el estima
justa
encuentres tus miedos
sus debilidades sus fortalezas su
propósito y ahora te pide a ti que tú
encuentres qué historia quieres escribir
para servir a la causa justa
gioda no es un líder de control es un
líder de descubrimiento
han notado que está pero siendo una boca
como
grande darth vader habla dice lo que él
quiere y cómo lo quiere cuando quiere no
escucha y llora tiene orejas como
grandes y verdes
y ahora escucha te deja ser quien eres
que tiene presencia paciencia confianza
escucha genuina
en la película nos encanta ayudar en la
vida real a todos nos pasa z trader
no porque somos malos pero por ejemplo
yo he escuchado gerente es decir yo
conozco este negocio y lo van a hacer
como yo digo y si no quieren aquí está
la puerta
o profesor es decir si tú no mejoras tus
notas de matemática voy a tomar
sanciones
o papá y mamá a decir presta tu pelotita
de futmi amorcito y te doy un dulce
no lo hacemos por ser malo lo hacemos
porque es rápido es fácil lo hacemos por
pereza o hacemos liderazgo de control
porque tenemos la ilusión que lo sabemos
todo
o tenemos miedo de no ser suficiente de
no ser bueno con los demás nos juzguen
el problema del liderazgo de control
absoluto no es que esté bien o mal es
que tienen es que tienen más costos que
beneficios
y también es un liderazgo incompleto
porque no se puede controlar a las
personas eso es una ilusión también si
yo controlo a un grupo quiero
controlarlo para ir de ave yo me quito
la posibilidad de la posibilidad de ir
hace de a efe a mucho mejor me quito la
posibilidad que la vida de los equipos
me den sorpresas
el tema es que nuestra historia humana
es una serie de sorpresas la tenemos que
generar las tenemos que disfrutar la
tenemos que aceptar
una gran sonrisa que yo tuve el año
pasado fue con la clase de liderazgo que
yo tengo el honor y la alegría de
facilitar en la universidad y mis
alumnos
decidieron como final de semestre como
proyecto final de escribir un libro
sobre nuestra clase
dijeron no nosotros somos 26 vamos a
escribir un libro en cinco meses con
seis capítulos y en el medio de una
pandemia
y lo lograron y ya no son solamente 26
alumnos son 26 autores aquí ven un poco
más que 26 nombres porque nos hicieron
el honor de invitarnos a participar por
ejemplo en ejemplo a mí me pidieron
escribir la conclusión
y saben de llover mi nombre en esta
lista
me da mucho orgullo también me da mucha
humildad
es una danza de emociones positivas les
voy a compartir dos grandes momentos de
este libro para mí el primero es la
primera frase enfócate en las personas
así empezaron sus libros mis alumnos
enfócate en las personas no en los
puestos no en los títulos no en los
estatus sino en las personas miran de
cerca mira sus hojas miras mira su ser
quiénes son y eso me hizo reflexionar
sobre lo siguiente liderazgo no es un
tema de compañías un tema de
asociaciones es un tema de vida de
personas
260 páginas más lejos cada alumno autor
puso su foto y unas frases o una frase
de sabiduría de liderazgo que es
liderazgo para él o para ella
les voy a confesar algo yo leo estas
frases casi diario los uso en mis clases
los uso en talleres de motivación nos
uso en compañías en cual yo trabajo es
decir en 5 meses mis alumnos se
volvieron mis maestros
y yo les tengo mucha gratitud por eso
y la verdad si uno sabe escuchar siempre
sus alumnos tus hijos siempre quien sea
si lo escuchas se puede volver tu
maestro
cuando yo les pregunte oye cómo lograron
escribir un libro tan bueno que ahorita
están negociando para publicarlo un
libro tan bueno que mi clase de ahorita
está tomando el material para hacer
podcast para hacer shows para ir de
guatelama de guatemala al mundo como lo
lograron ustedes y me dijeron cuatro
cosas primero liderazgo todos intentamos
modelar el líder que queríamos ser no
alguien más nosotros lo que queríamos
ser
y eso fue contagioso viendo eso cada uno
modelo el mejor líder que podía segundo
confianza como vimos que había confianza
nos atrevimos a hacer nosotros mismos no
pretender que somos alguien perfecto
sino yo voy a contribuir con quien soy
con mis grandezas y més debilidades no
importa eso es lo que soy auténticamente
eso es mi pertenencia genuina no encajo
en algo soy yo la escucha yo admiré su
escucha eso estos alumnos durante 5
meses obviamente hubo tensión hubo un
momento de debate de desacuerdo
hubo capítulos que no iban rápido que no
iban tan bien tuvieron conversaciones
difíciles pero se quedaron escuchando no
se separaron tuvieron la valentía de
seguir escuchándose en particular cuando
no estaban de acuerdo
y hubo presencia o vio solidaridad
cuando no estaba de bajón porque estaba
un poco cansado de tanto trabajo del
coach de todos conocemos bajones el
equipo estuvo en señor presencia hubo
solidaridad y todo eso creó una
experiencia colectiva que hicieron que
lograron un resultado extraordinario y
relaciones humanas extraordinarias
y eso me hizo pensar será que ahí hay
una receta un fórmula de liderazgo que
no sólo sirve en la clase sirve en la
familia sirve en el trabajo sirven las
compañías y la respuesta es si hay una
y es la fórmula que quiero compartir con
ustedes ahorita yo la llamo liderazgo
intencional de descubrimiento ahí cada
palabra es importante el rol del líder o
de la líder es tener la intención la
voluntad la convicción de descubrir
quién me está puedo lograr podemos
lograr juntos qué voy a hacer para que
cada uno se descubra descubrí aumentó y
aumentaba dentro de sí sus fortalezas
sus miedos navegar todo eso
y la fórmula es una multiplicación
quiere decir que cada vez que hacemos un
factor muy bien con el crecimiento es
exponencial pero cuando no hacemos uno
el resultado es cero no hay
el primer factor es la confianza la
confianza es un acto de valentía si yo
confío en ti pongo en tus manos algo que
es importante para mí es un acto de
valentía y de vulnerabilidad
hay estudios hecho por top consultores
en el mundo que demuestran que las
compañías sufren de un bajo de
productividad de 21% por falta de
confianza
también como líder o como contribuidores
queremos trabajar con el mejor talento
verdad el mejor talento no quiero que lo
controles quiere confianza
si queremos más resultados y mejor
talento alrededor de nosotros confiamos
más
el segundo factor es la escucha yo estoy
preocupado de ver la modernidad que nos
conecta con tener tecnología pero
nosotros mismos nos desconectamos por
falta de habilidad de escucharnos
miren en muchos países la mitad del país
no logra hablar con la otra mitad
entonces cada uno grita más fuerte
porque no se siente escuchado y eso
provoca emociones como rencor
resentimiento odio no son emociones
buenas para liderar yo sí siento
resentimiento no soy un buen líder no
soy una buena persona aún
margaret fernán que es una gran
facilitadora de liderazgo menciona esta
cifra mucho los ejecutivos y ejecutivas
de las compañías cuando hay un tema
controversial pero importante que sale
en la conversación 85% de ellos deciden
no hablar por miedo de represar ya por
miedo que les van a terminar el empleo o
se dicen igual nadie me va a escuchar
eso a mí me preocupa y yo lo quiero
resolver yo quiero que lo resolvamos
juntos tenemos que escucharnos más como
yo da esos grandes orejas
el último factor es presencia un líder
una líder tiene que ser presente no vale
decir yo confío en ti entonces haz tu
cosa ahí nos vemos el año próximo no si
algo es importante tenemos que ser
generoso
tenemos que dar nuestra intención no
prestarla darla es un regalo es un acto
de generosidad
porque esta fórmula es tan bonita porque
es infinita ven que ahí el seño infinito
arriba del lead de liderazgo intencional
de descubrimiento esta fórmula
transforma escasez en abundancia escasez
de relación en abundancia de relación
escasez de solución en abundancia de
solución es un liderazgo infinito como
lo es la vida como lo es el universo
como lo es la educación el aprendizaje
el negocio nunca para
tenemos que jugar este juego con reglas
de juego infinito también es más alegre
donde uno está más feliz en una zona
cómoda de 50 centímetros cuadrados o
explorando el mundo conociendo más gente
aprendiendo teniendo la humildad de la
valentía de explorar subir montañas
cruzar océanos obviamente que la segunda
parte es más divertida más alegre más
compleja también
y finalmente necesitamos el mundo de hoy
necesita este tipo de liderazgo porque
porque tenemos muchas soluciones por
descubrir soluciones socio políticas
ambientales climáticas tenemos que
resolver el cob y la pandemia todo eso
hay que descubrir y ese rol de los
líderes que la gente descubra la
solución es complicado porque supone
navegar tener la confianza de lo que sé
y la humildad de lo que no sé pero hay
muchos modelos para seguir miren los
artes marciales por ejemplo en los artes
marciales tenemos tenemos cinta blanca
es cinta negra
la cinta negra es la cinta del
conocimiento de la práctica saben que la
cinta negra es una cinta blanca suya
porque practicó mucho al tuyo
y tenemos la cinta blanca yo tengo la
mía aquí y me la voy a poner la cinta
blanca es la cinta de la valentía de la
humildad de la sabiduría de decir yo no
sé eso aún lo quiero aprender en mi
invitación amigos y amigas es que todos
nos pongamos nuestra cinta blanca todos
los días y nos declaremos eternos
principiantes
[Aplausos]